BUT FIRST, BUSH AND THE GLOBAL
ELITES STRIKE BACK.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
"ANGLE."
FOR EIGHT YEARS DURING
BARACK OBAMA’S TIME IN OFFICE,
HIS PREDECESSOR, GEORGE W. BUSH,
WAS REALLY QUIET.
HE PAINTED A LOT.
REMEMBER THIS ONE HATED OF THE
DOGS?
THEY LOOK LIKE GOATS.
AND W GAVE SPEECHES AND HE WROTE
AN AUTOBIOGRAPHY.
HE DID A LOT OF GREAT CHARITY UP
APPEARANCES FOR THE MILITARY,
BUT HE REFUSED SATURDAY TO A
MIST OF CRITICISM AS OBAMA WAS
TAKING A WRECKING BALL TO
FOREIGN POLICY.
LET’S THINK ABOUT IT.
WHEN THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
APPENDED OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM,
BUSH SAID NOTHING.
WHEN OBAMA RAN THROUGH HIS
BLOATED STIMULUS BILLS AND
EXPLODED OUR DEBT, BUSH WAS MOM.
WHEN HORROR STORIES OF NEGLECT
AT THE VA SURFACED, TOTAL
SILENCE.
WHEN THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
ABANDONED ARMED MEN IN BENGHAZI
AND THEN SENT SUSAN RICE OUT TO
LIE ABOUT THE ATTACK, WELL, THE
CAT HAVE Ws TONGUE, AND THEN
CRICKETS.
WHEN HE WAS ASKED TO COMMENT
ABOUT OBAMA POLICIES, THIS WAS
BUSH’S CUSTOMARY RESPONSE.
>> I DON’T THINK IT IS GOOD FOR
THE COUNTRY TO HAVE A FORMER
PRESIDENT UNDERMINED A CURRENT
PRESIDENT.
I THINK IT’S BAD FOR THE
PRESIDENCY, FOR THAT MATTER.
>> Laura: BUT SINCE TRUMP WAS
ELECTED, GEORGE W. BUSH SEEMS
WILLING AND ABLE TO    EAGER TOT
OFF.
ALTHOUGH HE DOESN’T MENTION
TRUMP BY NAME, HE MIGHT AS WELL,
AND NOT ONLY IS HE CRITICIZING
OUR 45TH PRESIDENT, HE IS NOW
DOING SO ON FOREIGN SOIL.
THOUGHTS NICE.
TODAY IN DUBAI -- WHERE ELSE?
HE CRITICIZED TRUMP FOR ENDING
THE DAD
POLICY, THERE ARE PEOPLE WILLING
TO DO JOBS THAT AMERICANS DON’T
WANT TO DO.
AMERICANS DON’T WANT TO PICK
COTTON IN 125 DEGREES.
THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT WANT TO
PUT FOOD ON THEIR FAMILIES
TABLES.
OKAY, I’M NOT WILL FERRELL, GIVE
ME A BREAK.
HILLARY CLINTON COULDN’T HAVE
SAID IT BETTER HERSELF.
BUSH TRIED THIS ROUTINE BACK IN
2007.
HIS AMNESTY WITH A SIDE OF
BORDER SECURITY, IT DIDN’T WORK
THEN AND IT CERTAINLY IS NOT
GOING TO WORK IN THE ERA OF
TRUMP.
BUT BUSH DIDN’T STOP AT NEEDLING
TRUMP ABOUT IMMIGRATION.
HE ALSO OFFERED THIS TRENCHANT
INSIGHT ON RUSSIA’S ELECTION
INTERFERENCE.
>> Laura: IS THAT RECORDED ON
AN OLD BARBIE TAPE RECORDER?
WHAT IS THAT?
IF I WERE GEORGE W. BUSH, I
WOULDN’T BE SO QUICK TO BRING UP
RUSSIAN MEDDLING.
I KIND OF RECALL -- REMEMBER
THAT RANCH IN CRAWFORD?
HE WAS PRETTY COZY WITH PUTIN
WHEN HE CAME TO VISIT IN TEXAS.
REMEMBER, HE LOOKS INTO VLAD’S
EYES, AND I THINK HE SAW HIS
SOUL, AS I RECALL.
SO IT WAS OKAY TO TRY TO WORK
WITH RUSSIA BACK THEN, BUT NOT
NOW, RIGHT?
WELL, I SAY THIS ABOUT LOOKING
INTO PUTIN’S SOUL.
HOW DID BUSH SO BADLY MISJUDGED
VLADIMIR PUTIN?
LOOK, LET’S FACE IT.
BUSH IS REPULSED BY DONALD TRUMP
BECAUSE, NUMBER ONE, TRUMP IS
MORE OF AN ECONOMIC NATIONALIST.
AND NUMBER TWO, TRUMP’S ELECTION
WAS A REPUDIATION OF BOTH OF THE
BUSHES AND THE CLINTONS.
AND ALSO, OF COURSE, W IS STILL
SMARTING FROM TRUMP’S TROUNCING
HIS BABY BROTHER, JEB, IN THE
PRIMARIES.
>> POOR JAB, HE’S DOING OTHER
COMMERCIAL OF ME.
THIS GUY, HE IS A MANIAC.
THIS POOR GUY, I FEEL SORRY.
HE’S LIKE A LOST SOUL.
YOU KNOW, THIS POOR, PATHETIC,
LOW-ENERGY GUIDE.
>> I’M TALKING.
>> YOU CAN GO BACK.
YOU INTERRUPTED.
YOU APOLOGIZE, JEB?
AGAIN -- I KNOW YOU’RE TRYING TO
BUILD UP YOUR ENERGY, JEB, BUT
IT’S NOT WORKING.
>> Laura: OH, MY GOD, THAT WAS
SO FUNNY.
SO IT’S TO BE EXPECTED -- COME
ON, THAT WAS BRUTAL.
THAT THEY BUSHES WOULD RETURN TO
THE NATIONAL HABITAT AFTER ALL
THESE YEARS, PLACES WERE NO
UNQUESTIONED INTERNATIONAL TRADE
DEAL OR THE MASSIVE FLOOD OF
HUMANITY INTO OUR COUNTRY, BUT
IT’S PAINFULLY OBVIOUS THAT THE
BUSHES WERE NEVER COMFORTABLE
WITH CONSERVATIVES OF THE
REAGAN, BUCHANAN, GINGRICH, OR
CERTAINLY NOT THE TRUMP VARIETY.
THEY ARE COMFORTABLE, HOWEVER,
WELL, COZYING UP TO THE OBAMAS
OR HANGING OUT WITH THE CLINTON
CLINTONS.
>> I DON’T KNOW IF THAT MAKES
ANY SENSE, TOLD ME HE USED SOME
BIG BIRDS.
>> USED PROPERLY.
[LAUGHTER]
SO, PRESIDENT BUSH --
>> THIS IS THE POINT WHERE I
REACH MY BACK POCKET TO MAKE
SHORT MY BILLFOLD IS STILL
THERE.
[LAUGHTER]
I DON’T KNOW ANY BIG WORDS.
>> Laura: STARTS SWEET.
ISN’T THAT NICE?
BRINGS BACK SUCH GREAT MEMORIES.
LET’S GET BACK TO THE
PROPOSITION WE PUT OUT AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE SHOW.
WHY IS GEORGE W. BUSH SUDDENLY
SO VOCAL?
YOU WEREN’T GOING TO TALK ABOUT
SUCCESSIVE PRESIDENTS.
I THINK IT MIGHT HAVE SOMETHING
DO WITH THE ECONOMY TAKING OFF.
OF COURSE, THE CURRENT MARKET
CORRECTION NOTWITHSTANDING.
70% OF REGISTERED VOTERS IN A
NEW QUINNIPIAC POLL ESSAY THE
ECONOMY IS GOOD OR EXCELLENT
UNDER TRUMP.
THE SIMPLE ACT ON THAT TRUMP’S
APPROVAL RATINGS ARE UP TO 40%,
AND AN ECONOMIST YOU GO SURVEY
HAD HIM AT 45%.
THEN YOU THROW IN AN INCREDIBLE
STATE OF THE UNION, THE
UNRAVELING OF THIS RIDICULOUS
RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION -- WE WILL
GET INTO MORE OF THAT WITH
ALAN DERSHOWITZ AND KEN STARR,
THEY FEEL NOW THEY NEED TO
RESPOND.
THAT IS WHAT TRUMP IS DOING,
ACTUALLY WORKING.
THE PRESIDENT SHOULD WEAR THE
TIRED BUSH CRITIQUES AS A BADGE
OF HONOR.
TRUMP IS DOING WITH PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATIONS WERE UNWILLING
OR UNABLE TO DO, AND
PRESIDENT BUSH HIMSELF SHOULD
KNOW BY NOW, COME ON, THERE IS
NO CONSTITUENCY FOR PERPETUAL
MILITARY INTERVENTION, OPEN
BORDERS, AND TOTALLY UNPLACED
INTERNATIONAL TRADE DEALS.
MR. PRESIDENT, GEORGE W. BUSH,
YOUR BROTHER RAN ON THAT